pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce mot d'indépendance et le mot de l'air
c'est lui qui a conduit à léopoldville
le roi baudouin que la population a
clamé aux côtés de monsieur kasavubu
chef du nouvel état congolais le palais
de la nation avait attiré la grande
foule
là le roi allait proclamer
l'indépendance du congo devant les deux
chambres réunies et de nombreuses
personnalités étrangères parmi
lesquelles l'abbé fulbert youlou venu en
voisin
deux signatures enfin dans celle de
monsieur lumumba chef du gouvernement
congolais
mettez fin à 80 ans de souveraineté
belge
[Musique]
à tananarive quelques jours plus tôt
monsieur tyrannie président de la
république malgache et monsieur foyers
représentant le gouvernement français
avait paraphé des accords qui consacre
l'indépendance de madagascar
[Applaudissements]
puis au stade mahamasina le président de
sierra n'avait remis son premier drapeau
au détachement de la nouvelle armée
malgache qui allaient défiler devant
cent mille spectateurs
[Musique]
non
m
ainsi est né un nouvel état de 592 mille
kilomètres carrés et de près de 6
millions d'habitants
quel est il au moment où s'affirme dans
le concert des nations cette nouvelle
république de la communauté que la
france et la tunisie vont patronné
conjointement à l'onu il n'est pas
inutile de regarder vivre quelques
instants sa capitale au pied du palais
de la reine qui la domine depuis le
siècle dernier
le visage de tananarive a beaucoup
changé en trois cent cinquante ans
d'existence
[Musique]
sa population a atteint aujourd'hui le
chiffre de 200 6000 habitants mais si
ces rues grouillent de vie
c'est une vie sans agitation ou les
seuls signes apparents du changement de
régime sont les ouïes du référendum que
le temps n'a pas encore effacé
divers cultes se partagent la population
de la grande île
[Musique]
à tananarive on compte 90 mille
catholiques et 110 milles protestants
qui se ressemblent beaucoup en costumes
du dimanche
[Musique]
mais les mosquées y ont aussi leurs
fidèles et en particulier 1200 indien
adeptes de la secte dirigée par l'aga
quand les ismaéliens tananarive compte
encore une minorité chinoise
ils sont huit mille dans l'île dont
l'activité essentielle et le commerce
cette minorité à ces écoles
[Musique]
et
d'ailleurs tous les enfants de
tananarive vont à l'école et la tâche ne
leur est pas si les et puisqu'il ya deux
langues officielles a madagascar le
malgache et le français en tout cas
c'est certainement l'un des meilleurs
atouts de la république malgache que la
scolarisation soit assurée dans ce pays
à 100%
[Musique]
il reste que tananarive demeure la
capitale d'un pays avant tout agricole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'avenir de la république malgache
nation de paysans de pêcheurs et de
pasteurs passe encore comme autrefois
d'abord par les rizières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en ce dimanche qu'ils étaient pour un
parisien sur cinq aux dires des
statistiques
le premier dimanche des vacances allant
sont offert le spectacle de son corso
fleuri
seize chars aux inspirations les plus
diverses un millier de musiciens une
débauche de fleurs et le sourire d'une
charmante dufès couronné pour l'occasion
voilà un excellent prélude au
dépaysement à nu et les indiens tonnac
quant à eux ont d'autres moyens
d'étonner les touristes ne serait ce
qu'avec ce numéro de voltige
ces quatre hommes attachés par les
pièces symboles des quatre saisons
exécute 52 tours avant de rejoindre le
sol autant de tours que deux semaines
dans l'année
cet exercice est par tradition destinée
à faire tomber la pluie dans les quatre
heures qui suivent
et cette année en effet il a plu
[Musique]
palo alto en californie quelques
instants avant un record historique la
barre est à deux mètres 23 un grand
bonhomme arrive à grandes enjambées
c'est john thomass pour qui la pesanteur
n'existe pas et qui bat ainsi son propre
record du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en tchécoslovaquie les deuxièmes spartak
yade de prague offre l'occasion de
présenter un extraordinaire spectacle
athlétique une mise en scène à rendre
jaloux les plus grands producteurs de
cinéma américain quinze mille jeunes
filles et des milliers de jeunes gens
qu'on pose toutes ces figures orchestre
avec une précision qui tient du milliard
[Musique]
il est presque incroyable que l'on
puisse parvenir à une telle beauté
d'ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et même individuel on peut être sportive
et avoir autant de charme qu'une beauté
peinturluré pour festival de cinéma
après toutes ces figures emporte
l'adhésion des spectateurs pour qui elle
constitue un saab
à
[Applaudissements]
ces figures sont évidemment moins
symbolique pour nous cependant il est
incontestable qu'elle nous arrache un
cris d'admiration
[Musique]
c'est un carambolage que débute le grand
prix de l'acf à reims carambolage dont
la principale victime sera le français
maurice trintignant
pour lui le grand prix de france aura
duré dix secondes exactement
les concurrents qui va ce tant pis le
durera un peu plus longtemps bien qu'ils
poussent des pointes qui frise de 300 à
l'heure dans certaines lignes droites
d'ailleurs l'hélicoptère s'essouffle à
vouloir suivre les bolides
ils les abandonnent bien vite tout comme
vont abandonner les principaux rivaux du
grand favori jack brabham sur cooper et
ferrari qui lui font illusion pendant
quelques tours et puis l'une après
l'autre
hellcats
[Musique]
on
brabham cooper numéro 16 doubles et
redouble tous ses concurrents à
l'exception du belge olivier gendebien
élu britannique mclaren qui sont
cependant assez loin du tableau
[Musique]
les organisateurs ont tout prévu si vous
manquez un virage vous pouvez prendre le
chemin des écoliers pour revenir en
piste
la course est terminée brabham a gagné
il a battu le record de l'épreuve à la
moyenne de 2 112 à l'heure à ce train là
il suffit de quatre heures pour aller
paris à marseille
ce fut amusant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]